I do think I do think people should try
to work out cheating though like I like
I I think like it's about the kids it's
not about you you should try to work it
out okay yeah oh yeah you should work at
100 I don't want to like I'm no offense
people watching this but like they my
mom and dad got divorced when I was four
and it was because my dad cheated on her
and I don't think anyone should you know
I think cheating I don't inherently
think cheating is a good thing but I
think I sometimes wonder what would my
life have looked like had they been
together I wonder that every day how
would I have been you know I'm I'm
grateful that the way I am the way I am
now but I'm just saying like I know
there's a lot of girls out there who
have dysfunctional families and don't
have a father and mother that are
together and I've seen people with who
have their mother and father together
and they're very different people the
way they approach themselves the way
they talk to people the way they react
to situations they're just different
people and I think that's beautiful and
so like that's even like a reason like I
want I wish more people more women and
men would see oh I want to have a
healthy family I want to break the
generational trauma the generational
disrupt you know the generational
problems do you ever wish you stayed
absolutely really yeah well I wish we
could have worked it out absolutely so
what made you guys get divorced if you
don't mind me asking well I I came to
him and I gave him the very clear
parameters I was like listen I figured
this is happening it's undeniable we
can't deny this is happening so let's
just save our marriage and save our life
we have a great life and so I said you
know I need these three things to happen
and not only did they not happen but it
got much much worse and then it got
dangerous then it got violent and then
it got scary and then I you know then I
just felt like I didn't have a choice
because things got so violent dangerous
and scary so it went directly because of
cheating
it started off that way because there's
just so much lies and deceiving can I
trust this person and then but I really
really wanted to to make it work I was
like why don't we we'll just I have an
open marriage which I knew would
probably kill me inside but I was like
yeah I even offered it you know I was
like that's really really wanted it I
didn't give him a contract for a second
child I said you have to pay for the
chat like I just I really wanted the
marriage to stay together but I just got
scared so if it was just strictly
cheating do you think it would have
worked out then it would have been all
right no well I needed certain things to
change I needed some Securities that
weren't that weren't that weren't there
because I think always insecurities do
you mind saying or no well when I found
out that he was cheating I also looked
into like our life a little bit more
deeply and I realized that absolutely
nothing was in my name okay I had
nothing and I was like oh my gosh I'm in
a really vulnerable position here
because I never even thought about it
and so then I was like listen I need to
have some stake in our lives
and it was a protect protective
mechanism clearly
um and he was like no
no way can I ask a question so did you
did you put yourself in that situation
where you wanted to make it work for
Penelope for sure only all because you
loved him so did also I still love him
today and if he's watching right now I
mean I was hoping he would come to
London yesterday and have lunch with us
is he still single yeah
okay
would you ever get back with him
if I mean I would consider Penelope
thinks I'm crazy but I talk about it all
the time my dad would never get back
with her so it's like I don't I I don't
know
right now on camera no no don't do that
but can I ask a question but why
wouldn't you I know you said you would
you would you're doing it for Penelope
and I understand that absolutely you can
do anything to keep
um I think people would do anything
um for their children but
don't you think that you should love
yourself more instead of after what he's
done and I feel like you can do you
deserve better and you don't deserve to
be treated like glorified what being a
single parent was going to look like and
it was crazy because I had a single mom
so I should have known better but
honestly I think it's modern day child
abuse it is and I watched her and I
watched her in my I watched her growing
up struggle so much as one person to do
all the work at home like just one
person no support I mean it was so hard
for you like you were I remember the
nights you were like crying and it also
struck a a strong heart in my and for me
that was like I never want to have that
and I will do any anything and
everything my power to never create that
for my future family because that is so
it was so painful I don't wish that pain
on anything yeah
yeah because if I have a family I made a
I make a vow I make a vow I make a vow
to to God to higher power that I will
stick with this person for the rest of
my life of course I thought that I did
that with your father too but you know
it happened but I can never make up for
that for you not having a dad and there
was a spiritual disc like there was a
spiritual disconnection there
well our values were different I thought
we were an monogamous relationship but I
you know found out otherwise and uh
maybe it was a phase I don't know maybe
you can't change people I don't know but
you know it's sad I mean guys he still
admits this day he regrets what he did
he wished he didn't do what he did and
he and he and he wishes he could have
changed certain things so he's not like
doesn't have any remarks I just feel
like
majority majority of men do at some
point in their life will cheat
in a relationship they will and if every
woman leaves a man for cheating then and
you have all these you know motherless
and fatherless family but I think I
think that's a thing we're never like
we're never as women we're never told
like how men are naturally and like men
just want to screw everything so it's
like we've kind of been told that if we
get cheated on it's the worst thing ever
and it can't be worked and the man isn't
in the house there's a lot of
fatherlessness yeah women so I think
that most of I think that most of
society's problem really like come back
to single mother homes to be honest like
if you look at the prison population
it's like 80 single mother homes if you
look at
um youth suicides you're way more likely
to be abused as a child um you're way
more like every Big um I I spoke to a
homeless um shelter director down the
street and I said why why like are these
people homeless like because he has like
the worst type of homeless which is like
the street sleepers because there's
different like levels of people living
in cars there's whatever and he told me
that um he that most of these people
came from single mother homes especially
with like multiple baby daddies or like
whatever and they the kids I got ended
up getting taken and like put in the
system and they've never they don't know
any sense of stability or function
um and so if you look at all the like
major issues in society a lot are linked
to single mother homes and single father
homes don't have the same outcomes it's
not as bad but if you're seeing a lot of
if you grow up in a single household or
you see a breakup then in your head it
might seem like what you were saying
with your you can you can do this
because your mom will grow up in a
single home run so you might see it as I
this is something it's not easy by
something I can do and then when only
when you go through it you realize that
right this is mad but if we have a lot
more family units in the house and
working at things then the children get
to see like okay my mom and dad went
through this but they managed to go
through this route to to help and
because I've been through my in a
relationship where I've gone therapy and
I've gone places to to fix things you
get on Zan and even when you talk about
therapy earlier I don't think therapy is
there to fix things it's just there for
you to it is I hope not not I don't
think therapy is there to fix I think
it's there to help you understand
triggers and understand certain things
for you to maneuver it can never therapy
can never fix nothing
honestly to be very honest with you
after going to therapy for eight years
maybe 12 yeah I don't believe in therapy
there are other ways to fix your
problems and you can also just really
get over yourself honestly I just
decided to get over myself and that's
basically how I feel well I think I
think that therapy like it's Outsourcing
families because like usually you would
go to your siblings or you go to because
your your mother is going to have a
completely different take like if you're
let's say if you're in an argument with
your boyfriend she's gonna have a
completely different take on the
situation because she knows you you and
she knows you're positive and you're
negative traits so it's like if I tell
my mom like oh this person reacted to me
this way mom's gonna be like well
people are scared of that real truth no
I just think that the therapist doesn't
have that information they didn't grow
up with you but like you who knows your
daughter better than you but that's what
I'm saying she might be she might be
scared to go to her mom because she's
gonna get that harsh reality and
sometimes people don't want the harsh
reality you know what I'm saying no I
love it that's she raised me that way
though yeah like the way you're the way
people raise their children dictates
also relationships how people reacting
so she raised me giving me the hard
truth since I was little and I hated it
I mean I would scream at you and cry I I
used to hate her but that's what I'm
saying you hate no one likes it you know
I used to hate her but now I love her
and I give her like all the props to be
honest with me when I didn't want to
hear it yeah she told me I was fat she
was like movie you need to get up and go
work out like she reminded me of that
every day that's good that's so funny I
used to get mad at Mama I wasn't I
wasn't that big but I was like that
pretty pretty chunky and my mom would
always be like on me because I was just
this die-hard like tomboy and I just
didn't want to like look not and I still
struggle with it today David I'm like oh
my God I would be so much worse if my
mom wasn't like on me all the time
because when you're a kid you're just
like Mom like I don't wanna know her and
she's like this she has her master's
nutrition she's trained thousands of
people yeah I'm like I don't want you to
tell me what to eat like I don't want
you to tell me how to live how to work
out but I would sit in my room like
obese fat you know crying I was
depressed in my dark room all day and
she'd be like open the curtains rip the
curtains open be like
better feel good open now you know I'm
gonna take your phone away and I was
like it was like really intense you know
those are the kind of parents that you
need but I needed that because this
world is cruel and I've been through
some bad things and and having that her
mentality that she raised me with being
honest and saying penalty you need to
get up nope and I'll be this is not true
you know men there are men and women
like these are important things that she
taught me it's kind of funny like the
day you realize your parents were right
about everything like it's like it's
like you just wake up one day and you're
like
it was like around 21 or 22 for me I was
like oh my gosh my mom and dad raised me
so well and they were right about
everything they told me
we never listened through our teenager
Yes except for relationships oh yeah I'm
not listening to them for relationships
compared to those two
the guy she's dating very much yeah I
mean I think that I think that mothers
like actually we should ask our parents
about those like people we date yeah and
I actually he met my mom and my dad and
I I would I wouldn't have been with him
if they didn't like him yeah period
because that's just how that's just how
it should be but man like that as well
because even the girl I'm seeing now her
family unit is strong and I feel like it
wouldn't have worked if if her mama or
things didn't Enlightenment you get what
I'm saying totally and my family is like
my most important thing but my respect
that once the family is important to you
totally I'm close to you like I feel
like I feel like men respect women more
when they have that family Dynamic
whoever the even if the dad's not there
if the dad's day obviously is going to
respect it a lot more in it because he's
going to come differently but if if he
knows you have a strong support unit
with Mom cousins aunties whatever yeah
he is going to respect you a lot more
than if a girl doesn't really have the
same kind of support we're asking how
you find a good woman and I I also find
it really challenging to know when you
find a good man I mean I think by now at
47 you know it's challenging to find a
good man I think I found one whose
values a line but it's not that easy
it's not easy as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible